welcome once again to a special program
about the war in ukraine over the next
hour we'll be attempting to answer your
questions about the war with defence and
security analyst professor michael clark
well fierce fighting continues in the
donbass region in the east of ukraine
russia has told ukrainian troops in
several donetsk to surrender tomorrow
morning calling their resistance
senseless the last bridge between the
city and ukrainian-held territory has
apparently been destroyed by russian
forces but ukraine's troops continue to
hold out well as i say professor michael
clark joins me in the studio welcome
once again uh michael will crack on with
the questions we've had so many of them
during the course of today and the first
question concerns that situation of
course in the donbass christian asked do
you think we are coming to the end game
and the end game in russia's favor no um
it's got a fair way to go yet i mean if
the russians keep up this momentum this
this slow gradual grinding momentum then
they probably will take most of the
donbass eventually but the word is
eventually they haven't taken severe
donetsk yet which is the capital of
luhansk which is the smaller of the two
oblasts the two areas of the donbass
region and the ukrainians are making
them pay to take severe donetsk everyone
is saying you know reporters are out
there and they're saying this is a
critical moment well it's not
um the strategically important city the
two strategically important cities are
slaviansk and kramatorsk further in the
in the west those have to be defended
and the ukrainians at the moment are
fighting against vera jones to make the
russians pay a price before they pull
back i think first of all to alicia
schansk on the other side of the river
because the russians have still got to
cross the river the severity it's very
don the saverski donetsk river they've
struggled across that river in force and
they haven't yet they've made a real
mess of it twice
and ukrainians will have time to fall
back on their real strategic objective
which are the two cities of slavians and
cremators what about this bridge
reportedly being destroyed does that
make that plan
yeah i mean there's several there are
several bridges and a lot of them have
been destroyed and partially rebuilt it
doesn't mean that the ukrainians are
trapped it may mean that they can't
bring their equipment with them but they
can always get troops over a river they
can get them over in boats they can get
them over on makeshift bridges they can
throw military bridges over a river
create pontoon bridges it's always
vulnerable if you do that but this
doesn't stop the troops escaping it may
mean that they can't take their heavy
equipment with them in which case they
would disable it and then leave well
michael you mentioned they're making the
russians pay a heavy price but our next
question now asks i suppose but at what
price for the ukrainian forces uh this
one that asks um
how long can
ukraine continue to lose troops
that was the main pavlo grab bridge that
went down about three weeks ago and that
was the biggest bridge the best bridge
and that was down but they've worked
their way around it pavlo grad was the
main one but not it doesn't matter okay
but in terms in terms of the troop
losses by ukrainians you know president
zielinski says they're losing what one
to 200 a day 3 000 a month they are and
they can't sustain that for very long
but so are the russians russian losses
seem to be about the same level i mean
russian losses you were much higher than
ukrainian losses in the other battles of
kiev and kharkiv and so on now that this
is a real second world war style
toe-to-toe match
in the donbass they're fighting in a
sort of almost 1940s 50s way
their losses are about in the streets
blockbuster absolutely block by block
hand-to-hand it's it's i mean it's about
as dreadful as you can ever imagine from
a soldier's point of view
and their losses are about about the
same neither of them can sustain 3000 a
month for very much longer and so there
will be a pause there will be a pause
while both sides take a breath and can i
just ask you does that matter of
fighting does that negate the russian
advantage when it comes to artillery and
long-range because you can't really
attack
the other side if they're cheated by
joel well of course no that's right i
mean one of the reasons that ukrainians
have stayed toe to toe with the russians
to stop them using their artillery but
what the russians have been doing is
flattening everything in front of them
and then they walk in over
over the rubble i mean the the one thing
the russians are good at which they
always were and they've proven that they
haven't got anything else in their
locker than this really which is to
flatten um urban areas and then as it
were invade the rubble and if
another side in this case ukrainians are
prepared to fight in the rubble and the
ukrainian army is good enough to do that
then even that's not straightforward so
they can keep destroying areas but their
progress is extremely slow extremely
slow we all expected them to be to be
even for russians we expect them to be a
lot quicker than they've been i mean
some of them sometimes they're making
less than a kilometer a day and some
days not even that and some days they're
getting pushed back and they're they're
drawing more and more troops into us
very donetsk into this particular battle
and they're getting thinner and thinner
in the north in kharkiv in the south
incursion well that's the next question
i wanted to ask you about so moving on
then to the south as you mentioned there
kershaw nick wants to know will ukraine
manage to finally break through and
retake kersham because it seems the
russians have never been able to to
entirely pacify they haven't and there's
a lot of um resistance in kershawn and
malitapol a lot of a lot of what the
russians will call terrorism now against
russian troops and collaborators and so
on it's pretty ugly stuff and it's
breaking out on the streets of kirsh on
the streets of malitopol
the ukrainians say that they think they
are going to retake kirschen i mean i
think they might be a bit optimistic
about that but they have launched a
pretty big offensive across a 50-mile
front and they've crossed the inulits
river again crossing rivers is really
important in military terms they've
crossed the inulits river to the north
uh west of kirshen and they're trying to
get around the back of russian troops
incursion while they also
attack them from the west
so that they're trying a two-pronged
attack against kershawn and what they're
finding is that the russians are now
pretty thin incursion because they've
taken a lot of troops away for this
donbass offensive and i don't know if
the ukrainians are being too optimistic
about this because even having crossed
the inhulits river they're still 40
miles away from the city but unlike the
russians more like western forces the
ukrainians make rapid progress they move
quickly and they move efficiently when
they do move so we'll see i mean i i
think in the next couple of weeks we'll
find out if this offensive against
cursion to retake cursion is going to be
a success or not okay well let's stay in
the south because our next question
follows on from that situation louis
wants to know do you think mikaliv and
odessa are the next targets after don
bass or kharkiv and dinipro so
if
donbass is relatively secured by russia
where would it turn its sights next i
think the answer to lewis is yes exactly
michael ivan odessa are more important
strategic targets for the russians
because to take odessa would landlock
ukraine it would it would make ukraine a
landlocked country i mean the russians
remember they've already got um
mario poll
they control the sea of azov they've got
berdyansk those ports on the other side
of crimea to the east of crimea the big
port to the west of crimea of course is
odessa and that's that's the third city
it's ukraine's third city
so yes they want they need to take
nikolayev because mikolive is the
gateway to odessa even though it's 80
miles away so they've got to take nick
alive and then they've got to cover the
80 miles to odessa um and those are big
objectives they've completely failed
once they've been thrown back from
nikolayev which is why they're now
struggling to hold on to cursion it
seems but if they could then release the
troops in the donbass
give them a break
and then redeploy them to this area then
i'm sure their next uh strategic
objective would be to complete this land
bridge all the way across southern
ukraine that's quite a big if isn't it
if they take the dawn bass and we deploy
the troops which has risks in itself and
then you've got to occupy territory and
the
rest and deployment takes a long time it
does and that's why i mean i i think you
know people keep asking me about what do
i think is going to happen um and i
guess we're going to talk about it a bit
later on maybe but um
the ukrainians have shown they can fight
the russians to a standstill more or
less anywhere in ukraine what they can't
obviously do is kick them out take back
the territory that they've lost they're
trying but that's a different sort of
objective and so i think that they could
i think the ukrainians will be pretty
successful at defending odessa even if
the russians can redeploy from the
donbass in say two months time
i think they will but we will say
warfare is
more unpredictable in sport
indeed okay a couple of questions coming
up about the air battles and uh ken
wants to know why aren't ukrainian
forces attacking russia from the air
because in the past in these programs
we've discussed how there are still
ukrainian air force there are planes in
the air they've got about half of their
air force left they started with about
120 combat aircraft they seem to have
about 50 or so
uh left they're getting some more the
mig-29s but they the mig-29s are an air
combat aircraft um
for fighting age other aircraft they're
not really a ground attack aircraft the
the su-25s are the ones that are ground
attack and so to attack russian forces
from the air if they need more su-25s
and they are getting some of those
but remember they're also attacking the
russians from the air with drones so the
bay raxter drone this turkish drone
which costs 1 20th of the cost of an
american or a british drone i mean
they're cheap and cheerful but they work
and the point about bay raptors is it's
not that they're any great technological
breakthrough just that you can have lots
of them and if you can have lots of them
you can obliterate whatever's on the
ground even if you lose half of them so
the bay rafter drones have been
extremely successful they've got lots of
other sorts of drones even tiny ones or
little copters that drop a grenade and
on a little group of soldiers who don't
even hear it drops a grenade and there's
any amount of footage that shows exactly
that happening so they are attacking
them from the air
um but you know russian forces have got
their own air defense the ukrainians are
losing aircraft and they they do need i
mean they do need to to rework their air
force if they're going to stay in this
war over the next months and into next
year well mark asks the other side of
the coin now about
russian forces in the air why has russia
not committed more of its air force to
the war for both bombing and ground
attack missions presumably i mean
they've got a huge air force we
mentioned that from the start of the
campaign they have yeah i mean they're
active the combat air air power is not
much more to be honest than about 800
aircraft it's not the three or four
thousand that are there on paper uh even
five thousand by some estimates but it's
more it's more like up to a thousand and
it's more likely to be by some estimates
as low as 750 800 850.
however um and and they committed about
230 240 to this operation at the
beginning they've clearly committed more
than that now their problem is not the
number of airframes they've got
available it's the ability of their
pilots and their command system to do
air ground coordination
so um even with more aircraft they find
it difficult actually to bomb things on
the ground and they're lousy really
lousy at bombing moving targets and it's
not because they can't aim um as they
work it but but the idea of getting
moving targets is that first of all
you've got to detect the movement then
you've got to see the target get
somebody um back at base to understand
there's an aircraft within 30 miles get
that aircraft over the target before it
disappears now western air forces are
very good at that well i mean it's not
down to
humans or technology it's it's both it's
training they've got the technologies
but they haven't trained for it they've
done so little air ground support um
exercises it seems in the past and so
that they have a command problem is that
although they can bomb fixed targets the
way anybody can bomb fixed targets i
mean reasonably accurately reasonably
they haven't got many precision guided
weapons i mean the the j dams these are
the bombs the joint attack demolition
munitions which are bombs that can be
directed they free fall but they can be
directed left or right and so on um they
haven't got many of those so they drop
dumb bombs second world war bombs that
they go wherever they go according to
how the pilot releases them
so they drop a lot of those but they
still can't use really accurate weaponry
to get onto a target within a couple of
minutes of discovering that it's moving
along a road and you want to get it
um and ukrainians are very good at doing
that that well let's talk about those
targets that the ukrainians are hitting
because uh another question from mark
not sure if it's the same one but uh
mark asks what happened to the russian
t2 tanks we heard so much about well
that tell us it's much feared t2
what's happened what's it terminator are
they there yeah it's not actually a tank
it's it's a bmp it's called a bmp2 the
terminator 2. it's a tank insofar as
it's it's on a tank chassis it's on a
t-72 standard tank chassis
and um you know it's often said that a
camel
is a horse designed by a committee
well this is a
an armored fighting vehicle designed by
a committee they've taken a tank chassis
and they've piled onto it all of the
weapons that soldiers say they want
so there it is it's got two 30
millimeter cannons it's got four rocket
launchers at the back it's got two
grenade launchers it's got a heavy
machine gun it's got smoke grenade
launchers it's got everything on it and
the crew is all inside doing all this
remotely now i've never been inside one
of these things very few people have i
can't imagine what it's like inside
because the amount of transmission belts
the amount of ammunition that must be
going backwards and forwards while these
things are available is staggering
the russians have been boasting about
this for a long time they had them
available at the um
at the mayday parade i think was in 2018
and it broke down
um and they haven't been at the mayday
parades until this year and this year
they were due to have three and only two
turned up so we think that one of those
broke down as well
they've only got one troop of these
terminator twos these bmps um and that
troop was been sent to severe donetsk
and that is either eight or ten
so we think the mod thinks it's only
eight
others have said it's probably ten but
at most they've got ten of these things
they've sent mrs philia donetsk we
haven't yet heard how they're getting on
but i suspect it's a camel i suspect
it's as vulnerable as any other t-72
even though it's got all this weaponry
piled on top of it so you think someone
that would be knocked out someone that
probably broken down
i'm very interested to hear how they've
been getting on i mean they've been
there now for over two weeks they don't
they haven't turned the battle that's
for sure okay um last question for this
section and uh interesting one this um
from em
why is there so
little incredibly little front line
combat footage one might almost be
tempted to wonder if it's all made up
well that bit no it's not em but uh
there is that question why is there so
incredibly little front line combat
footage why isn't it emerging and you
know in an age of social media who's
controlling it oh damn it there is and i
mean you know you know i mean sky's got
lots of this stuff and it doesn't use it
for reasons of propriety and decency and
we see and those of us who are in this
analysis business we see it all the time
look i'm looking at this stuff all the
time on twitter and not on youtube
particularly but other sources and a lot
of it's horrible it's horrible
so yes there is plenty of footage
um it's not that this is being invented
in some way or that there isn't a lot of
material there's masses of material
and a lot of it is just too nasty to
want to spread around um and so what we
see is
um you know what's available and what
the news channels choose to to put out
but i mean you know you've seen some of
the stuff as well it's it's well there
is that argument though isn't it that in
a way it kind of sanitizes water as you
say you know it's it's brutal it's
horrible yeah do you know the person who
said that most was norman schwarzkopf
remember stormy norman from the gulf war
of 1991 and he said i can't remember the
exact phrase something like war is
ultimately obscene it is obscene and
disgusting when you're in it
and and it is i mean warfare brings out
some of the best of human nature and a
great deal of the worst
and i mean anybody who's been in
firefights you know real close
firefights not remote artillery jewels
whatever anyone has been in firefights
you know will never ever forget it and
will always be marked by the experience
and even you know
artillery and people look you see films
and people sort of duck down to the
foxholes and explosions going i mean if
an artillery shell lands anything within
about 50 yards the shrapnel flies all
over the place and so quite a lot of
people will be injured or killed within
about 50 yards of one shell landing you
know they say i mean you know sitting
under not
onto an artillery barrage is one of the
most frightening things you could ever
do because the sheer extent of the
shrapnel the reality of warfare and it's
certainly not made up um we're taking a
break you're watching sky news coming up
we're going to be discussing then
vladimir putin's aims and what victory
could now be looking like for the
russian president
[Music]
welcome back we're going to turn now to
vladimir putin and uh what his
objectives may be now after initially
attempting to remember to seize the
capital kiev in the early days of the
war what does victory perhaps now look
like for the russian president michael
clark as you know is here answering
those questions and uh let's kick off
with this one from ian which is uh the
state which has been asked an awful lot
about uh of vladimir putin's health uh
michael do we know i mean is he really
ill or is this just wishful thinking the
thought being that you know he's on his
way out he's 69 and um he's launched
this war now
because it could be his last horizon
while he still can yes on the 7th of
october he'll be 70 that's his birthday
the 7th of october and um he is known to
hit the botox quite heavily um i always
say that he's trying to embalm himself
while he's still alive he does take a
lot of botox
he is
he he moves around with doctors there's
known to be a little team of doctors who
are never far away and it's said that he
leaves meetings at frequent intervals to
go and consult with somebody um i
suspect that he's only a hypochondriac
to be honest um it is it's often said
look has he got has he got cancer he's
got pancreatic cancer he's got
parkinson's disease when you see him
in these clips that we're seeing
increasingly frequently now that kovid
is over and he's now coming out of the
the shadows as it were where he's been
for over two years and he's making it
clear that he's in control he's doing
this he's doing that he looks all right
uh and i again i've spoken to a number
of people who said you cannot detect
parkinson's disease from the way he
walks you cannot detect symptoms of
cancer just by looking at the
photographs so i you know these stories
will circulate
um but there's no convincing evidence if
if he is ill
or becomes ill that would be one way out
for russia to say that the president has
stepped down and the the war will now be
prosecuted by you know nikola patruchev
who's every bit as nasty as he is but at
least it would be a change of face uh
which the west might then be able to do
something with but that's just a side
possibility really okay let's uh talk
now about the alliances that they've
built up namely with china i guess al
asks is russia sourcing weapons of
munitions from other countries or is it
purely relying on its own reserves is it
is it getting anything from china and
others yeah it's trying um
what it most needs is components and so
a lot of soviet equipment a lot of old
soviet equipment and some more modern
russian equipment has been sold around
the world in the middle east to india
to some african countries and the
russians are scouring their customers to
try and get some of it back if not whole
weapon systems certainly ammunition
which they're pretty short of precision
ammunition and some of the other more
specialized things um they have they've
we know that they've asked china uh
quite early on actually after about a
month fighting for weapons and the
chinese have have not said no but they
haven't helped either it's believed that
china has given them some help of a
relatively low level type of not
non-lethal but things which are not
directly uh ordnance direct weapons so
yes they are trying to source mainly
components in the rest of the world and
yes they are relying on their own
reserve stocks they're dipping deep into
their reserve stocks now and so we're
not we're now seeing some of these t-62
tanks what are these these are older
versions the older version 1960s version
the real cold war versions of tanks and
they are now appearing in the battle
space um so yeah the russians are
struggling and sanctions of course have
had a big effect on their own armaments
industry because their tank factories
the two big tank factories that they've
got are almost at a standstill for lack
of components
because they imply you know they get
their components basically from the west
i have done okay and what about the
fighting forces themselves i mean we've
heard particularly in the in the last
week about considerable numbers of
conscripts being used by russia
is bruce says is it mainly the army
composed of conscripts
in in in total terms about 50 50 which
is to say that the the peacetime army
which is the russians are relying on
because officially this is still
peacetime this is a special military
operation not a war
so putin hasn't mobilized and the
peacetime army is 280 000 and every year
around about april there is a new
conscript um intake of 135 this year it
was 134 500 i think it was so you know
about half of 280 000 is replaced every
year so another group comes in for a
seven month training period and over
that period about half the army leaves
so this peacetime army is in a total is
in a a period of transition and one year
conscription is no good to anybody you
know you train you spend seven months
training somebody
and then they do five months of
of work and then they're back in the
civilian sector now what the russians
tried to do is during that period when
somebody's conscripted they say look
your life is a conscript is miserable
isn't it we know it's miserable actually
we make it miserable for you sign a
contract become a professional soldier
for two years and your life will improve
from tomorrow and so what they've been
trying to do is bring the conscripts in
persuade them pressurize them to sign
contracts to increase the size of their
army but they haven't been terribly
successful and putin promised at the
beginning of this operation that he
would not employ conscripts in the
forces fighting in ukraine and that
promise has gone by the board because
there are lots of conscripts in ukraine
uh lastly in this section uh back to the
the aims of the russian forces and um
stuart says if russia wins these
southern regions let me add in the
eastern ones as well will they then try
for kiev again perhaps with chemical
weapons or nukes because of a lack of
ground troops so in terms of objectives
if the donbass is secured the bits of
the south say they don't go for odessa
could they go for kiev again
it is certainly the case that president
putin wants to eliminate ukraine from
the map as an independent state he wants
ukrainian territory and people to be
part of russia the way he believes
mistakenly for because he's got a very
eccentric view of russian history for
the last thousand years
but he believes that ukrainians are
really just little russians that's what
used to call them little russians um and
so that is that will remain his ultimate
objective it's been his objective since
at least 2008 and we can we can you know
look at that in the speeches he's made
the things he said so that's his
ultimate objective so yes he would like
to get kiev at some point
would he
launch a chemical or a nuclear attack
against gear i don't know
i mean kiev is one of the
jewels in the crown
of slavic culture kiev was founded in
the year 482
so it's more than 1 500 years old it's
older than moscow you know kiev is the
center of slavic culture which gave us
russia
would you would he destroy it with a
nuclear weapon if he tried to would the
order be obeyed we've talked about that
before i suspect not in the case of kiev
so no i don't think and chemical weapons
we have to say are remarkably
inefficient as weapons on the
battlefield they really don't work
terribly well they work
only in very specific specific
circumstances
when they when the british first used
chemical weapons in the first world war
the germans used gas first in 1915 when
the british used gas later on in 1950 in
the battle of lewis they gassed
themselves
it's very unpredictable very
unpredictable anyway um
so yes kiev is still a target but not
with chemical or nuclear weapons okay um
we'll take a break now much more about
uh
russia's objectives in the second half
of this special program you're watching
sky news tonight coming up we're going
to be discussing the international
response to the war
as president zielinski of ukraine makes
another appeal for long-range weapons
[Music]
welcome back to this special program
answering your questions about the war
in ukraine we're going to turn now to
the international response to the war
professor michael clark is here to
answer all your questions and uh here's
the first one for this section kevin
asks if his world leaders predicted we
knew
putin was going to invade ukraine why
did the west not stop power weapons and
train the ukrainian military ahead of
the invasion well i suppose to a certain
extent the the west did
start that process yeah after 2014 that
process began and the british were in
the lead on that with operation orbital
was what it was called and we trained 22
000 ukrainian soldiers which were
basically an officer call
and the americans were also heavily
involved in that what we didn't do until
much later on was provide lethal weapons
we provided equipment but the there was
a sort of reluctance to provoke russia
by giving lethal weapons to ukraine but
what they did i mean ukrainians were so
um they were wiped out in 2014. their
military was undermined by uh by
effectively traitors who were
pro-russian and and just gave things
away you know gave away territory and so
on they were on the floor in 2014 which
is why putin expected him to be on the
floor this time and the ukrainians had
the good sense to go back to basics and
they said what do we need to do
and british and american or american
british trainers with some help from
other european and nato nations helped
them to build up a western force from
the ground up they did the basics so
they started from scratch and produced
what is now a very western style force
that does things in a very western way
which is one reason only one reason why
they're doing so well um so yes quite a
lot was done however this question of if
world leaders knew well yeah i mean
american and british intelligence knew
back in october last year that this was
building up to an invasion and they told
the world in december yes that's when
they were in town
and they told ukrainians in october but
the fact is that ukrainians didn't want
to believe it i mean they sort of half
believed it but they didn't want to and
other intelligence services were saying
the opposite and french intelligence
services in particular were actually
saying no no we're closer to russia we
know the russians because of the
relationship between france and russia
has always been historically closed we
know what they're thinking they're not
going to do this this is all bluff and
bluster they really won't do it and by
the time we get to january this year
when the detention was really building
up there was a sort of a war of briefing
and to be honest i mean french
intelligence seemed to have been
briefing against american and british
intelligence and the ukrainians weren't
sure what to do and i say that
live on tv because a i knew it to be
true and b the head of french
intelligence was dismissed
um
you know by president macron
as a result of this problem that they
got it completely and utterly wrong so
the ukrainians i think were faced with a
real dilemma and they there was a degree
of avoidance a degree of just denial but
it wasn't that they were unprepared but
they they could have preferred prepared
better earlier and we could have given
them more lethal aid better earlier and
i know again for a fact the mod our our
ministry of defense was trying to give
them weapons from 2014 onwards and the
foreign office and downing street just
wouldn't have it
because of this
they weren't necessarily wrong in saying
that but they were making a judgment
don't give them lethal weapons well
let's talk about the here and now and
this continued cry from president
zielinski for these long range weapons
and uh sue asks why the uk and the us
dragging their heels on promised
long-range weapons a promise is a
promise are the uk and the u.s dragging
their feet or other countries as well no
i mean the the ukrainians are getting
the howitzers that they need these um
you know houses with a range of 20 odd
miles these heavy howitzers they're not
getting any of ours those are the as9
tiers which are very old now and we're
getting rid of them ourselves and i
think it wouldn't be sensible to send
them but they're a much better howit and
we're re re-equipping there are much
better howitzers uh in the business the
particularly the german one uh the
the the pan the panzer how bitzer uh
2000 best in the world and the american
called a triple the m triple seven and
they've got apparently 90 of these uh m
triple sevens they've only got a handful
of the panzer hour bits um and they've
got they are getting some multiple
launch rocket systems but again only a
few a handful the americans are sending
seven units but with lots of rockets and
we said we're sending three units with
lots of rockets now if the ukrainians
have only got 10 actual launch systems i
guarantee that in a month's time of
fighting those they'll be looking if
they've still got two still operational
because the russians be looking for
these things if they know they're there
and in in battle
you know you you lose equipment you know
a lot the attrition rates as they say
are very very high so it's undoubtedly
the case they are getting longer range
weapons
promises are made and these things are
beginning to arrive but not in anything
like the numbers that they really need
they've got they're getting plenty of
howitzers but the things that will make
the difference are the multiple launch
rocket systems which have a range of
about 60 or 70 miles and can have a
range if you put a missile on them of
180 miles not just a rocket but a
missile now we're not going to give them
missiles but we're giving them rockets
um but they've said um aristov who is
the uh adviser to the defense ministry
in kiev said look we need 60. and i
think yeah i mean pal you need 60 in the
first tranche and then you're going to
need 60 more after that i need them now
um
i suppose a broader question coming up
now this one just i suppose about the uh
about the support are europe doing their
bit or just doing a lot of talking as
usual well different countries are
taking different approaches yeah
i mean you know europe the european
union and we see that you know there's
uh uh slavonda land who is the president
of the commission with zelensky i guess
that's a photograph from the last couple
of days
i mean only today
she in the european commission said we
are recommending to the european council
which is the heads of government that
ukraine now be given candidate status
in the eu as an eu member that's
something the ukrainians have really
wanted that will be a big political
message whether she's overreaching
herself or she has done in the past i
don't know but the commission is going
to recommend to the government to the
27th government that ukraine be given
candidate status which means that it
will get a lot more help in economic
terms which believe me it's it needs
so there is that side of it also the eu
is on its sixth round of sanctions and
he's now negotiating a seventh round of
sanctions
they've got problems with hungary who
because the hungarians all ban in
hungary uh prime minister orban doesn't
want to go in for a seventh round but
they're trying to negotiate that so that
sanctions have been pretty important and
individually lots of european countries
like the netherlands and spain uh and uh
romania and bulgaria they're sending the
material that they've got and
interestingly one of the things that
britain is doing which was only uh
mentioned in passing about a week ago is
that the raf has it says has delivered
it caused thousands it doesn't say how
many thousands of tons of munitions from
one european country to ukraine to
poland one assumes where they can go so
we're not just sending our own weapons
the raf is using it using its transport
fleet some of it to move other european
weapons around to help the ukrainians
so the rf is doing something else which
you know nobody seems to have picked up
question here then from lee about that
about the the weapons being supplied in
all their forms um
how do western arms make it to the front
line intact when they have to travel
across the whole of ukraine don't the
russians have intelligence as to the
route they take aren't they vulnerable
yeah you know i used at the beginning of
this process i thought that would be the
case and when talking to people in the
ministry of defense they said no they're
quite relaxed about it said partly
because there's lots of the railways
system is still operation it's very
dense railway system in ukraine very
traditional one it's a different gauge
for everybody else's which you know it's
the old soviet gauge which isn't helpful
but never mind um so they've got these a
very dense railway system so that they
can move things around the russians find
it quite hard to attack the railway
system um and it can be repaired quite
quickly the road system is also it's
more sparse but as we were saying
earlier on the russians find it quite
difficult to attack moving targets so
they are getting the stuff through
and there's a degree of subterfuge
involved and yes the russians are you
know they're using their intelligence
and occasionally as we've seen in the
last week they look as if they've scored
some pretty one or two big hits
on weapons stockpiles that have come
straight from the west and they've
destroyed brand new systems you know
quite big ones so i mean the russians
are getting some success in this but in
general
most of what is being sent is finding
its way reasonably quickly
a matter of several days
not 24 hours but several days it's
finding its way to the front line okay
uh next question this one from buster
about uh how far the west is prepared to
go uh how far are you getting the west
willing to go to secure victory in
ukraine well you know not as far as
putting boots on the ground of course
yeah and it's going to have to go a lot
further than it's gone so far in my view
i think i mean i think what buster is is
kind of
implying i don't know if he was thinking
about this um is that putin if putin
gets most of the donbass in the next
couple of months i think he will offer
some sort of peace deal or some sort of
truth some sort of ceasefire arrangement
and then the western
consensus which has been very tough so
far very determined will tend to split
and then we'll find out how far the uk
and the west is willing to go because
then we've got to decide a question that
you and i have talked about before both
privately and on camera you know is the
west trying to end the war or help
ukraine really win it
if we're trying to end the war that
might happen reasonably quickly
if we're trying to help ukraine win this
war for the sake of civilized behavior
and the international order and legality
and so on then we're going to have to do
a lot more than we're doing at the
moment we're going to have to be
prepared to take more risks
but take some hurt ourselves both in the
effect of sanctions and in the economic
downside of of re
militarizing what we are prepared to
produce and send to ukraine
and possibly um you know i think we're
facing a series of thresholds between
now and next year which we'll either
cross or we won't
to get a bit more directly involved a
bit more okay uh back to the situation
as it stands and how it may develop this
from jay if the donbass is lost to
russia will the west continue to arm
ukraine in order to retake the donbass
region this is the issue you were
touching on earlier about the
ukrainian's ability to to fight the
russians to a standstill but not
actually yeah but not throw them out
yeah and that's why to to to actually
conduct a strategic offensive which is
be to actually throw the russians out of
large parts of the areas they've taken
certainly since the 24th of february the
ukrainians need more heavy equipment
they need more more equipment that can
be used in the offensive they need to
rework their command structure and
they've got to bring you know quite
large forces of their troops who are
very nicely dispersed and working very
well in relatively small units
relatively and they've got to start to
bring them together for these big
offensives
that will take some time and the west
would have to back that we'd have to
back it now at the moment everyone is
saying in the west we'll do whatever the
ukrainians want if they if they decide
to go for a ceasefire then through
gritted teeth we would support them
because they're the ones doing the
fighting if they decide no they're going
to fight on to free to free up their
territory we ought to support that as
well and that's easy to say at the
moment
but it will it be so easy to say in
august and september and october when
other things are getting difficult what
about another way of getting i mentioned
their boots on the ground uh this from
mark should more british veterans join
in the fight with ukraine to show a sign
of strength and uh they're the images
we're showing of course are the the two
british veterans being sentenced to
death in the breakaway donbass region we
know of others that have been killed in
the battles aslan and the pinner yeah
um yeah so aidan azlin isn't it and uh
sean pinner
i mean point one is you know real battle
spaces are absolutely no place for
amateurs
or you know willing recruits who got no
experience at all which you know these
two guys were quite experienced
um
if anybody is
determined to help the best thing they
can do is to go to the border go to
poland or romania and help with the the
background aspects and the you know
expert hands can be very helpful but if
untrained people end up in the battle
area they'll either you know they'll get
hurt or killed very quickly or they'll
be used as cannon fodder because
there's not much else that they can do
veterans is a diff are a different issue
and the government is not encouraging
veterans to go despite what the foreign
secretary said i think on the 27th of
february
um speaking without thinking i'm afraid
um the government is not encouraging
people to go because even if you're a
veteran i mean these two guys were there
for four years yeah and so they're
thoroughly integrated were integrated in
absolutely
i mean aslan in the marines and pino was
in different units i think but both of
them were proper ukrainian soldiers who
were taking ukrainian pay and were you
know they happened to be foreign
nationals just as fijians and samoans
serve in the british army foreign
nationals serve in the british army
perfectly legally and they were foreign
nationals serving in the ukrainian army
but veteran you know veterans going out
now to fight to help again it's hard to
fit them in in a way that makes any
military sense because even if they're
quite used to military life
they're just one person with a different
set of training standards and a
different sort of way of doing things
different weapons they've been trained
on not the ak-47s and so on it's
unlikely that they can make that much
difference nobody knows how many british
soldiers or british individuals might be
there they think somewhere between 50
and 100 they think maybe 20 have been
killed but those these are just sort of
order of magnitude guesses from what we
pick up okay michael uh for the time
being thanks we're going to take another
break
you're watching sky news coming up next
we'll discuss what could happen next in
ukraine and weather
and end
maybe
some way in sight
[Music]
welcome back we're going to end the
program now by discussing what we should
expect in ukraine in the coming weeks
and months and whether an end to the war
could be in sight as you know professor
michael clark is still with me here
answering your questions this one then
from matt asking just that the situation
in ukraine appears to be deteriorating
certainly in the east what might the
next couple of months bring
well if i had to guess i mean as i say
that you know war is is more
unpredictable than sport by and large um
and
i i would expect that the ukrainians
will continue to fight for the donbass
fiercely
and that the russians won't get all of
the donbass but they they'll get luhansk
uh and and what they've got of of uh
donetsk can maybe a bit more donetsk but
i suspect that the ukrainians will
actually make gains in in
splitting the russians up in kharkiv in
the second city further north
and they might i think the ukrainians
really want to get kirschen back and so
i think that in the next couple of
months the ukrainians will as we've said
fight the russians to a standstill in
the donbass and the russians might say
well that's that's okay we've got as
much as we want but they may well then
find that they are losing
uh in the south and the ukrainians i
think will make some gains however those
are all sort of tactical gains what
we're really looking at is a kind of a
stalemate between both sides and i'm
sure given the the usage rates the
attrition that we're talking about the
losses of i'm i'm of troops i'm sure
that both sides will take a pause
because that's what happens you know war
goes in fits and fits and starts it has
to and i think there will be a there'll
be a pause before hostile a cease-fire
or just well i think i think the
russians will offer some sort of
ceasefire in order to put pressure on
the west
um and i don't think that
if the ukrainians don't accept it i
don't think we should pressure them to
accept it but i think you know
ceasefires are one thing but actually
pauses uh acknowledge pauses between
both sides or another
what about the economy though we talk
about the situation
the war situation deteriorating clearly
the ukrainian economy is in a parlour
state can the ukrainian economy survive
andrew asks considering the marijuana
steel works not under their control
little wheat is being farmed and so many
other money-making facilities being
attacked and destroyed well
the good news on agriculture is an
astonishing 90 percent
of the crop for the next crop has been
sown because most of the agricultural
areas of ukraine have not been
particularly affected by the war but the
industrial areas have because the
industrial areas are those in the east
of the country from uh uh chernihev uh
right down to mariupol really
and the ukrainians are looking at a drop
in their gdp at the moment of 45 which
is catastrophic
and the cost of reconstruction if the
war stopped now
the cost of reconstruction is generally
estimated order of magnitude of about
600 billion dollars
and somebody's gonna have to pay for
that
um and of course the the eu and the g7
are now thinking well the russians
should pay for it and you know there is
one trillions worth of russian private
assets in the western world
and should they be seized in order to
pay for this there are some big issues
there the not least the legal issue on
on what legal basis you seize it but
that's the nature of the of the problem
the ukrainian economy is going to be on
its knees at the end of this exactly is
that you know the british economy is
completely bankrupt in 1945 because we
devoted everything to fighting what was
for us a total war that's exactly what
the ukrainians are doing so the fact
that they've lost 45 percent of their
gdp is only the where they are now
somebody
you know the western world has got to
actually help them through the war
however long it lasts and then we've got
to devise some way of helping to rebuild
them
and everyone is working on well what can
we what can we make sure the russians
provide to rebuild some of the damage
well our next question asks how do we
get to that point and i suppose it's
based on what we were discussing earlier
what you were saying there about a pause
would ukraine settle for the loss of the
donbass region if it brought about a
lasting peace deal and i'd add to that
how do you know it would be a loss yeah
i think they wouldn't and i'm sure they
wouldn't i mean they might they might
have to acquiesce in the loss of the
donbass but they nev they will not
accept it because they don't believe
that russia bears them anything other
than ill will they do believe that
russia wants to destroy them there will
be a pause to regroup exactly i mean
they've been peace deals signed before
haven't they absolutely anything they
agreed to would be on the basis that it
was temporary as far as kiev is
concerned because they fundamentally
don't trust russia under putin and
probably russia under whoever comes
after putin i think we're talking about
a third generation of leadership before
we can get back on terms with russia
which i would put sometime probably in
the 2030s
another question as we uh imagine what
an end to the war might look like and
this from the from the russian point of
view given what putin has promised the
russian people uh given russia's
infamous history of propaganda is it
possible even if ukraine wins the war
that putin will claim otherwise and say
actually they won and achieved exactly
what they set out i mean in a way that's
kind of a a messy peace deal isn't it
where you can both take something away
yeah it's it's what they will say anyway
um and i knew i mean if president putin
says well you know we've got enough of
the donbass now this is i've preserved
the integrity of the russian minorities
and the donbass who were suffering from
all these nazis in kiev who were
terrorizing them and that's his his
narrative a the rest of the world will
see that's not the case b the donbass
will not be peaceful any more than the
the land bridge will be peaceful around
kershaw i mean the ukrainians will keep
resisting the russians will not will not
be able to as it would go home and just
leave a civilian administration there
they'll need to keep their troops there
so there'll be this grumbling war and
while that's going on the world will be
saying oh yes well this war was was was
undertaken to tell nato not to enlarge
and nato has now got quite a lot bigger
because sweden and finland have joined
nato which are the two most important
new members since 1994 and russia is a
pariah and russia is under sanctions for
as long as you're in control mr putin
that's a great strategic victory that is
you know i remain the master strategist
everything he wanted to achieve
is is actually going exactly the
opposite direction and a lot of people
are paying for it with their lives well
carol follows on from that then carol
asks this how will russia be accepted
after the war and it's precisely the
point you'd be making not just today
michael it is
putin
is the big problem if he's still there
how will the rest of the world regard
russia yeah
sanctions will remain for as long as
putin is there i'm sure about that and
you know putin may not be there for so
much longer
uh we're waiting for some sort of coup
to take place so you know you can't
guarantee whether it'll be in three
months time or three years or five years
time um and that and that poor
individual is um vasily nebenzia who is
the um
the u.n ambassador russia's u.n
ambassador and he has probably the worst
job in the world because he's the one
who has to say stupid things he has to
deny that any of this is happening he
has to pretend that all of the bombing
in mario poll was done by the ukrainians
that they're bombing themselves that
they're killing their own women and
children in order to blame the russians
and he's a bit like um zorin um
ambassador zorin in 1962 in the cuban
missile crisis
you know the russians didn't tell him
what was happening he didn't know what
was happening and um adelaide stevenson
he suddenly said what about this and
what about this and zone said no no it's
not happening not happening and then
adelaide stephenson went to the
blackboard and he unveiled all of these
photographs of the missiles and cuba
said what is this mr ambassador what is
this what is this and he made him look
really ridiculous and nebenzia to me he
looks like a latter day zorran um i'm
i'm just waiting for the guy to defect
you said there michael you're expecting
the coup
i mean anytime soon that putin will be
removed
he yeah he's got nowhere to go uh russia
has got nowhere to go under his
leadership and this war will get worse
for russia even if he succeeds in the
donbass or even if he was to succeed you
know as we said in in taking odessa
which is only you will um
the people around him are beginning to
lose very heavily and although they
depend on him for their kleptocracy i
mean russia is a mafia state and again
that's a that's not my phrase that's the
phrase of most good analysts it's it's
become a mafia state and so the only way
that the people around him can preserve
any of their privileges and wealth
eventually is to remove him now who will
start that we don't know because he's
also running a reign of terror which is
now
every bit as bad as stalin's reign of
terror was
up to the point where stalin died in
1953.
michael so you know the future for him
the the outcome is certain the timing is
uncertain